I'm a passionate woman and then a woman
with depth and with desire for me almost
been more about surrender help me open
my orgasm confidence and clarity
it's a connecting to that like a sexual
and powerful women inside the story is
about a company called one taste that is
a sexual wellness company that teaches a
practice called orgasmic meditation when
it feels that good you don't want to
move an inch
everyone should be experiencing this and
talking about this part of our lives
this is the food I was searching for you
know and that I didn't have a name for
and they were calling it orgasm how did
they sit it's like orgasm is God desire
is the force on this planet meant to
grow us into the person that we know we
can be this is so incredible and I
really genuinely want everybody to have
access it just felt so understandable to
me how they could take those first steps
toward something that ended up in a
place that was really predatory and
maybe even a cult
[Music]
my name is Ellen Hewitt I'm a reporter
for Bloomberg and I wrote the story the
dark side of the orgasmic meditation
company one taste has several different
philosophies that kind of guide what it
does they first and foremost believe
that doing the orgasmic meditation
practice which is a fifteen-minute
partnered clitoris stroking practice
helps open up your connection to your
body your desire to other people
basically it just does many many good
things for you and they see it as a
practice that should be taught alongside
meditation and yoga ohm is a partnered
practice where the upper left hand
quadrant of a woman's clitoris is
stroked lightly and deliberately for 15
minutes some of the benefits of ohm
include feeling confident and self
expressed increased vitality learning to
use desire is your guide better sex and
deeper relationships you know some
people just take a few classes and some
people it becomes their life and I think
for those in the group where it really
takes over their life some people love
it
and some people feel like it's the worst
thing they've done I spent a long time
talking with she's named Esme Hall in
the story that's just her first name she
struck me as someone who was just really
relatable she was in her late 20s when
she joined she had been a teacher in New
York and she had recently gotten out of
a relationship she was feeling a little
low and thinking to herself maybe I need
to meet some new people make a change in
my life and she encountered one tastes
the way that many people do which is
through one of their free events
yeah you would show up and it's much
people and maybe you do something like
play communication games and she leaves
with this impression that these people
are really like they figured something
out and they continue to get in touch
with her and they said hey you know if
you want to learn more about orgasmic
meditation maybe you should take our
intro to ohm class and this is a class
where you you know they talk about the
philosophy of one taste a teach you
about orgasmic meditation they have a
demo in which the two teachers
demonstrate one ohm session in front of
the class
so how we'll do it is I'll describe
what's going to happen and then I'll
bring in two people to do the
demonstration for you and then at the
end of the day's class they would let
students pair up if they wanted and try
orgasmic meditation for the first time
so that's what she did
and after that you know they just kind
of kept getting in touch with her and it
happens gradually and then all at once
like she got closer with these people
she left her job to come start working
for one taste and she moved out of her
home to move into an ohm house as they
called it in New York I don't think
there are very many places in the world
where we can feel a full range of
emotions even to their highest intensity
and not have to shut them down and one
way
I've had people describe orgasm to me as
a force almost like the force from Star
Wars so people would talk about how like
you know listen to your orgasm like what
is it telling you and like is it telling
you to do this for that and they would
rely on people who were very advanced
and one taste to help them understand
how they should be sort of following
their orgasm hi everyone so my name is
Maya I have been oming for eight years
now
I was in the class and I remember this
experience of feeling like I was having
questions answered that I didn't even
know I had the question of the people I
talked to who got involved seemed really
similar to myself they just seemed
really normal right these are people and
I felt that there was something pretty
universally human about what they wanted
they were looking for community meaning
they wanted to belong to a group of
people who felt like they were working
all together towards something really
special and important for a while it was
very popular within the group to believe
that if you were having sex with a lot
of people that you would free yourself
from the things that constrained you in
terms of how you related to other people
and they often talked about how
preferences were something that would
hold you back and this meant that you
gain sort of more spiritual
enlightenment if you had sex with or did
sexual acts that you didn't want to
it taught members to ignore their
personal boundaries about what they did
and didn't want to do ultimately ohm is
a practice so you don't need to be
turned on or in the mood to do it in
fact ohm cultivates libido and so me
holders taking more classes you knew
these classes are very expensive it can
cost anywhere from several hundred
dollars to some of them are thousands of
dollars for a retreat and you can pay
sixty thousand dollars for a year-long
membership which lets you take any of
the classes you want so quickly she
started spending more and more money it
kind of leads into this larger teach
that one tastes had which was that money
is just sort of an emotional obstacle to
getting what you want going into debt to
pay for courses was really common this
was actually something that salespeople
at one taste would encourage students
and customers to do they would say oh if
you really want this course you'll you
know you'll find a way to pay for it
look you could even open a new credit
card there was a woman who I was I was I
was dating and she said hey I want to
take this class with you and I want you
to pay for it and I was like what and we
hung up the phone
and I just sat in this chair and I could
feel the desire start to almost like
necrotize inside of myself I could feel
it starting to die and I picked the
phone back up and said okay wait wait
wait I want to do it the company
pressured customers to buy classes and
to even take on debt by classes the
company used sex to get sales and they
did this in several different ways you
know we have people who talked about how
they were as salespeople instructed to
own with or have sex with somebody who
was then called up to you know by a
course
partway through the year or me HoloNet
somebody in one taste they got married
they got married at a one taste retreat
and all of a sudden she and her husband
they just had sort of gotten swept up in
this whirlwind of the one taste life
she was in around $20,000 in debt she
and her husband together had spent about
$150,000 that's their estimate
eventually soon after they got married
Nihal kind of reached a breaking point
for a variety of reasons she was feeling
really stressed someone that she worked
with who was like her closest friend in
one taste left and over time she and her
husband decided like we need to leave
leaving one taste is this very lonely
thing because once you leave the group
people inside the group are told that to
never talk to you people sometimes refer
to people who had left the group as dead
and so you can feel very lonely because
you have left this group that was you
know your friends often the people you
lived with the people you worked with
and you often break from them very
suddenly and then you don't really have
anywhere to go and the people out here
think that the group that you just came
from is super strange and they don't
understand
are a series of allegations in the story
and one taste had different responses to
each of them so they say that they never
required anybody to have sex with each
other in the work context generally the
company says they never used sex for
sales and that this is not something
that they taught many people who had
past experiences with one taste said
that they felt pressured to take on debt
to buy courses and the company said but
we took money from people that we
shouldn't have and that we've changed
our policies since I saw parallels
between the way that one tastes ran and
the way that some startups run which is
like you really want to be part of a
tightly knit group that is charging
toward like a very unique solution that
has a lot of meaning that's what drove
people to become super involved in one
taste that's part of what drives people
to work crazy hours for very little
money for you know the chance at equity
at like some company that you think is
going to change the world and for many
of the people I talked to after the
story ran they were grateful that this
was something that was finally being
told and their reactions she's seeing
their personal and confusing and weird
and isolating story told in a major
magazine was really heartening to me and
was really meaningful to them
you
[Music]
you